-Our next guest is a very
talented actress and writer
you know from shows
such as "Rutherford Falls,"
"American Gods,"
and "Reservation Dogs."
She stars in "Echo,"
which is streaming now
on Disney+ and Hulu.
Let's take a look.
Please welcome to the show
Devery Jacobs, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
How are you?
-I'm great.
I'm in New York. Hi!
-Very nice.
And now you lived here
10 years ago very briefly,
but a different New York
than you're probably
experiencing on this trip.
-Oh, 100%.
I lived here as, like,
a poor, aspiring actor
10 years ago,
and I lived in, like, a bedroom,
one -- like, a tiny bedroom
that had no windows and, like,
was infested with cockroaches.
So now to be here and to have
Marvel be putting me up,
it's like a little bit
of a different experience
than that was.
[ Laughter ]
-Always try to
get Marvel to pay for it.
-Yeah, I'm learning.
-Yeah, you're learning.
Before we move on to "Echo,"
which is terrific,
I want to congratulate you
and, basically,
everybody involved with
"Reservation Dogs."
Was such a special show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Three incredible seasons.
And you had such a cool arc
as an actor on that show,
because you also joined the
writers room and got to direct.
-That's right.
For the first season,
I was an actor,
and like Sterlin Harjo,
who's the showrunner
and the creator of the show,
like, he's noted me for years,
not only as an actor
but also, like, as a filmmaker,
writer-director.
So for season one, I was acting,
and I was just like,
"Hey, would I be able
to shadow a director?"
And Sterlin was like,
"Yeah, of course."
I mean, FX, like, bless them,
they're great.
They we e like, "Yeah, we kind
of brought you here for acting,
so if you could, like, focus
on that, that would be great."
But then, for season two,
I came in with, like,
my references,
I was, "Here's
all my writing samples.
Like, I'd love to be
in the writers room."
And Sterlin was basically like,
"Yeah,
you don't have to do all that.
Like, come in.
Like, be in the writers room."
And so, from there on,
I was able to co-write
an episode in season two,
write a solo episode,
episode nine of season three,
where Elora Danan meets her dad,
which turns out to be
Ethan Hawke -- spoiler alert.
[ Laughter ]
And, um --
And then also got to direct
an episode in season three.
-It is a show where I imagine
being in the writers room
is so special
because it was, you know,
critically lauded
for its authenticity.
And being one of those
really authentic voices
must have been a cool feeling,
knowing that you were making
the show what it was.
-Oh, it was incredible.
Like, everyone
in the entire show,
whether it was directors,
whether it was actors
or writers,
everyone was from an Indigenous
community and different nations.
So it was something
that was really special.
It was a show
that was really groundbreaking.
It's bittersweet that we're on
our final season releasing,
and it's going to leave
a big hole in the industry,
but it's the hope
that there'll be many,
many more to come from there.
-This is also, when we speak
of authenticity, in "Echo,"
which is wonderful.
You have to, obviously,
we saw, do a lot of
American Sign Language.
Was that something
that you have to teach yourself?
-I didn't teach myself, no.
There were really
incredible teachers
from the Sign Language Center.
There was also Douglas Ridloff,
who is the ASL master
and one of the producers
on the project,
who was just, like, fantastic.
But, yeah,
getting to learn
that language was a privilege,
but also, like, a lot of
pressure and making sure
that we were able to,
like, communicate with Alaqua,
who's, like, a legend in her
own right and is so badass.
It was -- it was really awesome
to be able to do that.
And it's something
that I'm still learning
even after --
after the show's wrapped.
-So, you were -- you played
a character, Bonnie, in this
that was not in the comics,
which is very --
-Yes.
-When they make a character
for you in a Marvel show,
that's a big deal.
-Oh, 100%. It was great.
-But you -- also, not your first
Marvel role.
You were in "What If...?"
and you voiced this character,
which is
also pretty badass.
-Thanks.
-And was that --
This was your first entry
into Marvel.
And was this a cool experience,
getting to do this show?
-It was incredible.
So, I auditioned for
"What If...?"
and the character of Kahhori,
who is Mohawk,
and I'm also Mohawk.
I grew up in Kahnawake
Mohawk territory,
and they were looking
for Mohawk speakers.
I am not
a fluent Mohawk speaker,
so this was a lot of pressure
also to make sure
that we got it right.
My doda, my grandmother,
is the principal --
used to be the principal
of the Mohawk Immersion
Elementary School.
My niece is a first-language
Mohawk speaker,
and so it was really special to
be able to work on Kanien'kéha
and to be able to bring
that character to life.
But Marvel actually didn't --
Like, the "Echo" people
didn't know
that I was already
in another Marvel project,
and they asked on set,
and I ended up bringing it up,
and they were like,
"Oh, we had no idea."
And I'm like, "I know,
because I didn't tell you that."
[ Laughter ]
But I couldn't have imagined
that, like,
these two very different
Marvel projects
would have come out, like,
within weeks of each other.
-It's very nice.
It speaks to your range.
Congratulations.
-Oh, thanks!
[ Laughter ]
You did not, uh --
[ Applause ]
Acting was not
your first choice for a career.
Or, I should say, you probably
always wanted to be an actor,
but you had different plans
for yourself, professionally.
-I mean, I always wanted to be
in film and television.
It was my dream.
But, like, growing up on my rez,
there was really no clear path
to do that.
So I actually, like,
could be considered
a certified corrections officer.
-Okay.
-Um, which was
a very different path,
but I wanted to be able to go
towards social work,
which would have had, like,
the applicable credits.
And I figured
if I wasn't able to pursue
my love of film and TV,
then I wanted to be able
to help Indigenous people.
Um, and then I was
cast in a role,
and I was like,
"I can't do anything else.
I just --
I love this too much."
But the hope is that I'm able
to do both of those things
of, like, advocate
for Indigenous rights
and also be able to
be a storyteller in front
and behind the camera
in this medium.
-The fact that you can act,
write, direct,
and play two Marvel characters
in the same year,
I feel like there's no reason
to think
you won't be able to do
everything you set your mind to.
Thank you so much
for being here.
What a delight to meet you.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You guys, that's Devery Jacobs.
"Echo" is streaming now
on Disney+ and Hulu.
We'll be right back
with Nico Carney.